Let's start by undoing our latest change
and delete the photo frame entity.
So the model is as it was before.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Now we must create a new
version of our model.
Add model version.
You can call it however you want.
Model two seems reasonable and
it's based on our current model.
Now you can see that we have
two different model versions.
However, the previous one is
still marked as the current one.
We need to change that.
To change the current version of
your model, select your model.
And then, in the file inspector,
look for model version.
And current should be Model 2.
So now we have our new version
marked as the current one.
We should make all the changes
back to this new version.
So let's go ahead and
add the photo frame entity back.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
The last step, is to make a minor
change in our core data stack,
to make sure that it does the migration
from version one to version two.
We do this by adding two simple
options to the persistent coordinator.
Let's get it done.
We create a dictionary of options and
one is
NSMigratePersistentStoreAutomaticallyOp-
tion which is pretty
obvious what it's doing.
And we're setting it to true.
We want to migrate.
And we're also telling the persistent
store to infer the mapping model.
So we're telling you,
find out how you should migrate from
version one to version two, and
we simply pass these options when we
add a store coordinator and that's it.
Now it's your turn.
Grab your x code and
create a new version of your model.